what I want is an off-the-shelf sex
partner I want to be able to use a woman
whenever and however
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to episode 16 of
the 13 o'clock podcast 16 already 16
already I know gosh we've been doing
that but we haven't been doing this that
long but you know yeah already at 16
episodes yeah and we decided to do
another serial killer show yeah because
the responses are so good you sick sick
bastards out there maybe we'll get 2,000
hits on original Nightstalker so you
guys like serial killers gonna bring you
some more serial killers we like serial
cam this is some of the worst of the
bunch this this case is always disturbed
me from back when it happened yeah these
two [ __ ] man it Birds whoo anyway
but before we start on that um I wanted
to just give a shout out this past
weekend
December 2nd 3rd and 4th we were at
spooky Empire in Orlando
spooky um and we were invited to be on
some of the author panels and we were
there signing books and stuff like that
and it was such a great experience and
we just wanted to I wanted to especially
give a shout out to ad Samms the writer
she was the one that organized all the
authors and she was the one that
contacted us to be on the panels and
stuff like that she did an amazing job
like setting up all the panels and
scheduling everybody and I also wanted
to give a shout out to the other authors
that were on the panels with us and some
of these these were actually the ones
that were slated to be there but some a
couple of them weren't there but most of
these people were there so I'm just
gonna read their names and then we'll
get on to the serial killer stuff so um
we're just going to mention ad Samms
Christopher Helton Cynthia lot elise
reyes indy mcdaniel john Catapano Justin
Jordan Katherine Hearst she was not
there but her husband was Larry hey Dorn
Melissa give Oh Nicole black tous owl
going back PD mughelli rgg Jolla sareth
nee Scott M Baker Scott Marlowe Tim
Anderson Trent Duncan and Tyson Hanks so
look all those guys up most of them are
writers some of them do podcasts and
various other things so um
you'd also like to give a shout out to
all
we got yes exactly we met hey welcome to
13 o'clock go ahead glad you guys all
saw the other day yeah yeah fantastic
fantastic so okay these two douche bags
yeah oh man we're talking today about
Leonard Lake and Charles egg oh my god I
know these two for some reason like you
know serial killers in general are
scumbags okay and I and I understand the
fascination I find them fascinating I
don't like to glorify them necessarily I
know some people are kind of into them
like they're rock stars and seems to
take the cake but yeah for some reason
these two even though their body count
isn't as high as maybe some other ones
these two just I don't know they just
pissed me off more than most of the
other losers and I'm not sure what that
is but yeah they're kind of horrible so
um give a little background uh Leonard
Lake was the older of the two well first
of all what hand was this was late 70s
or lose
um I think most of their murders
happened in the 80s although they had
been arrested for various other yeah
they had long histories before they
started their little project um but a
Leonard Lake I was originally from San
Francisco and he came from a broken home
you know was a lot of them do parents
separated when he was six and then after
that him and his sisters were sent to
live with his maternal grandmother now
when he was growing up apparently he got
super into porn and he got into it
either as a result of or you know
because I'm not sure pal but he started
taking nude pictures of his sisters and
apparently his grandmother was all about
that shows like she encouraged it like
yeah I guess that you know my god I know
weird Leonard ladies man creepy so uh I
mean apparently he was kind of a an
intelligent guy as a lot of serial
killers are admittedly but um they they
also think that he might have molested
his sisters or been in consensual sexual
relations Lister's now this is all
shadowy and unconfirmed yeah
so well yeah or something like that also
as also with many serial killers started
with animal cruelty his thing was he
used to dissolve mice in acid dam which
is nice and so and that also served him
well later on in his later serial-killer
career okay um
he later on he and he actually enlisted
in the Marines and he did two tours in
Vietnam he was a radar technician and
during this time when he was in the
military he was actually in for a while
but then he had to go through a you know
psychological because I guess they
thought maybe there was something wrong
with him sure there's something wrong
with yammer psyche so they sent him for
a psych eval and turned out he had
schizoid personality disorder they
diagnosed that and he suffered a
breakdown and he got sent home on a
medical discharge in 1971 and then he
did go to psychotherapy after that
clearly it did not help him and um can't
help bad brains yeah and you know and
like I said when we've talked about this
a lot before serial killers you know
there's a big debate over born or made I
think it's a combination of two things
cuz I think a lot of people are born you
know maybe kind of messed up but if they
have like a normal loving upbringing
then they'll probably turn out fine yeah
but if you combine like a perfect storm
yeah this kind of genetic you know
predisposition toward that kind of thing
it then you grow up in this kind of
[ __ ] up home where your grandmother's
saying hey take naked pictures of your
sisters then yeah yeah I don't hit
around yeah you can see how that goes
so um he did go to college but he
dropped out after a single semester and
then after that he went to live in a
hippie commune and when he was at the
hippie commune um he he got married but
then the his wife at the time she took
off because Leonard Lake like I said had
a fascination with pornography and he
started making amateur porn films mostly
you know SNM type stuff good so um so he
but he got into this hippie thing and
then
he kind of got obsessed with the idea
that the earth was going to be destroyed
in a nuclear holocaust yeah
which is kind of I mean I had thought
that kind of thing didn't really come
about to the 80s like with all that kind
of stuff but I guess because of the
Cuban Missile Crisis and all that I
could yeah yeah people that thought yeah
okay so yeah he kind of got really into
that and um so when he was at this
hippie commune he lived he lived in I
hit be coming for eight years it was in
Northern California and that's where he
met his second wife her name was Clara
Lynn but he called her cricket and she
was actually in some of his porn film so
she was kind of into it at the beginning
she was into the porn aspect ok I'm not
she wasn't it didn't have anything get
with the killing but she was she was
into the porn aspect she was in a bunch
of movies he made um now because now
after he left the commune with his wife
like I said he was obsessed with nuclear
annihilation so he was wanting that to
happen actually yeah it did kind of
sound like that and so um his wife at
the time cricket she had um like a ranch
you know this this huge like 5,600 acre
hippie settlement right and um I think
it's up in California yeah Abigail ofor
knew somewhere and so he um he went
there and he got wit full-on survivalist
yeah build mothers like building bunkers
and like uh you know stockpiling weapons
and that kind of thing and then there
came a time when now this is not
confirmed but most sources say that it
is thought that he met Charles egg
through um a classified ad that he
posted in a survivalist magazine I'm not
like I said that I heard burn so I don't
know what the classified ad said like it
was just hey I'm looking for a
survivalist buddy or whatever I don't
know but um so that's apparently how the
two of them met that you know if that's
not how they met they don't know how
they
but so Charles Eng was the other guy now
he was a younger dude um he is a real
winner
yeah he was actually born in Hong Kong
in 1960 um and his family were actually
very wealthy but they were very strict
and abusive and yeah I was kind of a
shadowy part of the story too about what
his parents were like yeah get a whole
lot out probably not but that's that's
how the story goes
so apparently he came from a very strict
abusive household and he was also a
kleptomaniac and that will come in yet
not come in Haiti was also Marie - yeah
yeah he joined the Marines later but
yeah he was a kleptomaniac and that will
actually be important later but um so
even as a teenager he was stealing
things he got kicked out of a bunch of
schools they finally they sent him to a
boarding school in England where his
uncle lived and he started stealing [ __ ]
there - from the other students so they
kicked him out of there now he came to
the u.s. in 1978 on a student visa and
he was going to study biology in Belmont
California but he also dropped out after
only one semester so watch out for those
one semester comes from I guess is the
lesson there and it was about this time
that him and Leonard Lake hooked up but
there that's when they first met now
after not too long after the two of them
met uh Charles Eng was in a hit and-run
ass like he hit somebody and took off
and he got caught and to avoid
prosecution he joined the Marines now he
was not a citizen okay yeah so he had
fake papers and the Marines actually did
not know that he was that he wasn't a
citizen um he said that he had a
recruiting agent who helped him with all
these fake documents and whatever so he
was in the Marines for less than a year
and then because of his sticky fingers
his sticky fingers
he stole a bunch of automatic weapons
from the base where he was in Hawaii
yeah it was give us a couple cases of I
think it was m16s yeah yeah yeah and so
they were going to court-martial him but
he deserted so he went back to
California and as soon as he got back to
California he looked up Leonard Lake
again now these two he hooked back up
with him yeah after after that happened
after he got out of the Marines yeah and
then that wasn't quite when the whole
serial killer thing started because in
1982 the their little compound in
Northern California got raided and there
was a bunch of illegal weapons there
were explosives in there and stuff like
that I am I didn't know about that part
yeah all right so so I guess Lake at the
Leonard Lake at that point got released
on a six thousand dollar bond that he
took off using a bunch of different
names and stuff like that
Charles Eng got returned to the Marines
over there custody and he pleaded guilty
to the theft and desertion charges and
he actually spent 18 months in the
military stockade at Leavenworth as a
slap on the wrist yeah and then after
that he got paroled and then he was
dishonorably discharged so after he got
out of Leavenworth then him and Lake got
back together again cuz these two were
just apparently yeah it was a bromance
bromance what it was so at this point
when when Charles and contacted Lake
again um Leonard Lake had a cabin in
Calaveras County now I think I said
before that the the initial compound was
owned by his ex-wife but it was actually
this cabin that was so that was mistake
sorry about that but um so it was
actually this cabin in Calaveras County
that his wife owned his white cricket
cricket yeah so they were living on
those three of them were living in this
cabin and lakes I make it four
well yeah they were yeah there were yeah
and uh which would have been fine if
they had just left it it bad but no they
just had to take I know these guys are
so gross they're so yeah but okay so so
Leonard Lake says I'm he has an idea I'm
gonna build a dungeon next to the cabin
which you know never good I'd always a
red flag I would think and they're not
now the authorities are not sure but
they think at the point that the dungeon
started to get built they think that
Leonard Lake might have already murdered
two people okay one of whom was his
brother Donald okay the second of whom
was a man named Charles Gunnar who was
big fat guy I was a friend of his yeah
and had been the best man at him and
crickets yeah buddy
yeah his thing at first was that he
liked to kill people and steal their
identities Wow so like he was using
their wrong you their ID and stuff like
that and then we doing they're running
dart off as a sexual predator so not as
suckers often more like a guy that would
just kill you and take your stuff steal
your identity that's how he started
right and this is like yeah this is like
now it seemed like now obviously there's
no way of knowing this right but you
know obviously these are both criminal
[ __ ] right now if they had not met
each other
would it have escalated not as same way
it did I've studied this aspect of this
this case and I think what was going on
is that there was like you said there
was this bromance and this bromance of
these like minds to these just wackos
they had this synergy on each other
where one was constantly pushing the
other one to the different heights oh
yeah criminality right and they were up
there living in that cabin making
dungeons and bunkers and they were
ex-military guys and they were getting
together weapons and making weapons also
because they also had a Mac two
they had silencers and they thought that
they were these basically mountain men
like something from the 1800s where that
was their land they owned it they were
they were the law of the land and their
little compound they just did whatever
they wanted and that alone because the
isolation and the power they had just
over their little immediate vicinity
made them think that they could do
whatever they wanted to do and they
could get away with it indefinitely
yeah which it kind of was like that for
a couple years
yeah because honestly they didn't get
caught for the murders no wait I mean
you know I'll talk about that later how
they got caught yeah but yeah this is
what happens next let's just lose so
what so like I said they think he may
have already done two murders including
his brother so obviously he's you know
killing things start and it should be
noted too that even though a lot of
serial killers I mean they tend to kill
strangers you know generally and it's
also usually a sexual motive yeah which
these two had but later not at that
point um
these two kind of killed people that
they knew even if only tangentially
right
um so basically they you know they would
kill neighbors stuff like that so the
year after these two hooked up and like
I said Charles Lang was living in this
cabin with lake and his wife was still
there when at this point although she
took off later now do you think she knew
about the murder of his brother and all
that other stuff I'm not really sure I
mean she did yeah she may have yeah but
um taking one of the clan I guess you
could yeah so she was just amazed a well
that's on you guys right I mean you know
they didn't indict her so maybe they
didn't have enough evidence to say but
you know if those two murders did take
place while she was still there then
yeah maybe she did she did she did know
something about it baby
Lake was the kind of guy to brag about
it actually yeah and like I said he was
going around using other people's IDs
and taking their money and [ __ ] like
that
so so that so the next year was lake and
egg decided to kind of indulge this
grand fantasy that they had come up with
you know no longer content with just
making some harmless S&M porn they
decided that they were gonna go whole
hog and go with the torture and murder
and everything else because Leonard Lake
and maybe Aang to a smaller extent but
lake actually has um kind of manifesto I
guess that he videotaped himself talking
about yeah we can show you some quick
and yeah and I can show you uh let you
listen to some of this had to do with
him want to repopulate the earth with
his own with his own kindred after the
apocalypse and he was gonna need all
these women to be his brood mares yeah
and he was getting this ideas from this
book that he read yeah oh and I wanted
to mention that I was gonna say that um
that Leonard Lake his whole thing his
whole quote-unquote philosophy which is
what he called the video than he made um
was that he wanted women to basically
just be sex slaves he said I want to be
able to just [ __ ] them and have them do
what I want and then just stick them
back in a box somewhere yeah and I'm
like dude they have inflatable dolls now
did you not know that or you know well I
guess inflatable dolls won't do your
dishes but it's funny when you hear the
guy talk and there are some videos we
probably won't show them of him and
interacting with this victims yeah cuz
that is too creepy I'm not let's go with
some one of the weird things that you
get from watching this guy's that he
looks like a fantasy role player yeah a
lot of times the victim please interact
with the victims it doesn't even look
like a real situation it's kind of like
the victim is so much in shock that they
can't believe that this is happening the
guys kind of robotic and lizard-like and
whenever game is talking game if that's
your mind calling earlier yeah whenever
ings talking he also seems kind of like
a real cheesy fantasy role player like
he's playing it at being a ninja or
something like that it doesn't look real
on video but yeah this is very real like
I said there is I mean you know if you
are into that kind of thing you can see
the whole video um they have it on
YouTube there's it yeah they're on there
on YouTube and other places
is actually now I could just show I'm
just going to show a little bit of just
him talking because there this video or
this audio it does go on to encompass
yeah and if I remember correctly he's
making these videos in preparation for
this new project and it's to capture all
these women yeah yeah because that was
his thing so I'm gonna play a little bit
of his philosophy now so you know like I
said if you want to look the rest of it
up you can but I don't really want that
cause it's gross as [ __ ] so here so here
it is
good evening it's a Sunday October 22nd
23rd Simon I'm Pam close to my 30th
birthday and I'm starting this tape
without script or without any real
organization of what I want to say but I
do feel a need to explain what I want is
an off-the-shelf sex partner I want to
be able to use a woman whenever and
however I want and when I'm tired or
bored I'm not interested I simply want
to put her away lock her up into the
room get her out of my sight out of my
life
slay there's no way around it primarily
a sexual slave but nonetheless a
physical slave as well I believe that I
can if I can construct a holding cell a
place where I can put such a woman a
facility that is so stark so empty so
cold so quiet so totally removed from
the world that I can quickly condition a
young woman to cooperate with me fully
if you go on this quadrate with this
is nice as we can to you within the
limits of keeping you prison
you don't go on this probably taking the
bed tie you down
great you shoot you I'm very sorry times
up
Thank You choice
[Music]
why are you here who keep you busy
you'll wash Birds you're clean verse
good for us manse you try to the nut
shop not much of a choice unless you've
got damage
okay yeah so winner
yeah so thank you yeah I'm talking about
where he comes up kind of like a UH like
a role player yeah he's like really you
know no bad role players no offensive
role players little role players is just
this guy's a serial killer easy this is
some role he's playing and you can tell
it's kind of like and I guess this is
pretty common in a lot of serial killers
that these are dudes that are powerless
in a lot of ways maybe trying to
compensate for some we're trying to
compensate for something I mean because
why would they do it otherwise I mean
obviously well-adjusted they're normal
there's also you can kind of see if
there's something missing in their in
their personality their kind of lizard
like almost like a robot well yeah I
mean obviously they have no empathy run
for other people they just see other
people as objects that they can that
they can take things from maybe because
they're objects yeah and maybe we'll
deep down maybe that's what they think
maybe they just think well they're
nothing they're like a machine yeah so
no one else is anything either so over
the course of the year these two
[ __ ] um like I said I don't like to
glorify so what's the first ones that
they mad well there's kind of uh there's
so many and actually they didn't really
like I said they didn't really know how
many they killed they still don't yeah
these guys weren't ones that really
talked what once they were caught would
that we'll get to that oh yeah sorry
later but um this is something that a
case that mostly had to be put together
based on later on Iran by video
evidences because yes because evidently
at the time that these people
disappeared and were murdered um
they were not suspected right it was
only afterward when they were caught for
something else that people started to
get suspicious and went to the cabin to
check it out but some of the people they
killed they killed now another thing too
that these two [ __ ] did was they
would kill a whole family yeah that was
they would take well they only did that
because they just want
the woman right they would kill the man
and a baby yeah immediately they would
just shoot I'm like execute him and then
they would take the woman and put her in
this like weird secret room that they
had yeah and like make her do all this
[ __ ] there you know rape her and torture
her and stuff like that and avenging a
tape and videotape all of it and what
family was that well the one family it
was um it was actually their neighbors
uh Loni bond was their neighbor and he
had a girlfriend named Brenda O'Connor
and they had a baby son named Lonnie jr.
now Lonnie bond and the baby like I said
they were shot immediately Brendan
O'Connor was kept alive you know in
their little hole and they videotaped
her and did all kinds of horrible things
yeah they did the same thing with
another family yeah and I think I think
it was that family was the one that Ning
was drawing pictures of it when he was
in his prison cell but maybe that's
getting ahead of the story yeah I
thought yeah I'll say that later but um
cuz they were cook cuz that [ __ ] oh
my god oh my god like later on so I just
wanted to kick this guy in the nuts he's
still alive I think that the way so you
know he's a prison thankfully but you
know what he is still alive but the next
family um was Harvey and Debra dubs and
they also had a baby son named Sean same
thing Harvey and Sean were killed
immediately and Debra dubs was kept
alive and um you know mutilation all
kind of stuff yeah now they think that
they were separated first and then
killed so the woman didn't know that the
baby and uh yeah yeah there's no
indication that was cause like I said
this was pieced together row after the
fact I believe if I remember Chris is
all off the top of my head about this
case from what I remember they had a
written instructions for the so called
slaves that they had captured that she
had to go along with all this and she
had to keep herself looking good through
the whole thing in order to be reunited
with her family which is evidence that
she didn't know that the family was
already dead right yeah oh yeah and I
think there's photos of that yeah if I
can find them I'm pretty sure I saw
photos I'll put them in the YouTube
video with a little types you're a thing
that's called the rules or whatever
very neat in like yeah we just watched
Walking Dead last night so that's why
we're thinking of that negan's rules I
can hit you with a back but um so but
like I said they didn't they were into
capturing the women and keeping them and
torturing him and using him as sex
slaves but they didn't really
discriminate I mean they would just
pretty much kill anybody they and you
know they would get him by sometimes
putting ads out yeah and actually a few
of the victims they found uh one of it
might have been the Dubs family if I'm
not mistaken how they found them was the
debt the Harvey dubs had a um had an ad
for some audio equipment that he was
selling right
and um didn't write just plan on
stealing it but then they saw his wife
they just stole everything I know
everything her and Hammond so you know
scary you guys please you know don't
post stuff on these weirdos these
weirdos come as like you know it's just
like cray one of the video equipment
because that's what they were gonna make
their porn movies right and then they
figured hey two for one
yeah oh man so they also killed I mean
pretty much anybody some people came
looking for Loni bond and for Brenda
O'Connor and Lake and Aang killed them
too Wow and also I've been authorities
they were just civilians yes they came
looking because they said hey didn't
didn't think I'm here like weren't you
guys gonna buy something off them
weren't they guy was like mom oh my
never sure but yeah and they also killed
two gay men I'm not sure how they got in
contact with them they probably live
nearby or they've worked with them or
something like that um
now when the only reason they got caught
oh my gosh we're almost at the halfway
point yeah okay so let's let's actually
take a commercial break
mmm listen I'm just gonna take one
commercial break and just put all the
commercials in there we'll do that and
then we'll come back and kind of talk
about the rest of the case cuz there's a
lot left all right so we will be back in
just a few minutes ladies and gentlemen
project Entertainment Network presents
the mentor is the greatest manager of
all time mando Guerrero parts unknown
up-and-coming superstar the great boot
up yo man I'm not gonna teach members
never check out or write a book maybe
you do while they're at it
mark ignores Wilson Karen sweet Albahari
exclusively on project Entertainment
Network if you're into cosplay corsetry
steampunk gothic or rockabilly clothing
shoes and accessories then you must
visit subculture corsets and clothing
either online at www.haddadtoyota.com
code 13 o'clock and receive a 10%
discount on your entire order and if
you're a full-figured girl don't worry
subculture carries sizes four through 4x
and they have men's clothing as well
that's subculture corsets calm and use
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount go check out their website now
subculture corsets calm or when
traveling through Jacksonville Florida
stop in and check out their store at the
Avenues Mall
[Music]
I'm captain Dallas meet our character
turkey jerky project entertainment
liquid rock raffle podcast every Friday
talk to Tom Clark Steve massive and a
vodka
superkick Pro Wrestling in the hot spot
featuring interviews with
coming in as superstars lettuce table
that shoots while it works you can only
hear them on project entertainment like
a very village
hey everyone there's a brand new podcast
starting on December 1st the Dead TV
podcast where we take shows from the
horror industry that had been cancelled
or ended and review them episode by
episode starting with kindred be
embraced and Constantine you'll have to
stick around to see what the third show
that we're doing immediately after those
joining me for this amazing new podcast
is mr. zenica hello everyone thanks for
having me mr. Seneca is an event hostess
of kinky geeky and sexy parties around
the philadelphia area she has a flair
for the dramatic and is passionate about
zombies she also teaches on a wide
variety of BDSM topics including hi
protocol in fact you can say she wrote
the book on it which you can find in her
l website WWL can't let kinky calm
thanks so much I'm happy to be here
chris is a longtime horror fan and turn
that love of horror into an almost
decade-long radio show called radio of
horror he wrote a children's Halloween
book in 2012 called give me something
good to eat and has a comic book
forthcoming or he gender swaps the
entire counts of Dracula looking forward
to that on the side he also makes sure
horror films in Massachusetts so how
could I say no you can get all the
updates about our podcast on our
Facebook page the dead to you TV podcast
and eventually a forthcoming Twitter
page as well so stay tuned for the first
episode coming December 1st
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
there's hairos real and imaginary and I
write about them all paranormal
nonfiction or fiction a lobster guys the
manager is this table monster Red Menace
the Pretender Brucella whether go to
WWJD AFRICOM or search Amazon for the
Jenny Ashford author page
[Music]
okay yeah now here's these [ __ ]
again okay that wasn't all the victims
there was one girl that they took from a
store she worked at to remember that one
yeah yeah yeah okay they just walked
into the store told her that her husband
had been in an accident she had to dandy
well actually that was they what ended
up happening this guy I think it's uh
Michael Carroll I want to say was his
name he was actually a drug dealer okay
now they had killed him previously
alright but he had a girlfriend and she
worked at a source and like that and
they went to the store and said your
boyfriend is got arrested or he's in
trouble or something like that you have
to come and and then they ended up doing
the same thing to her yeah she made her
late yeah pretty much
and I mean they did eventually kill them
but they've got videotape them in so
like I said since they killed all the
relatives and stuff that came looking
for these people that were missing no
one really suspected these two of you
know murdering anyone really how we got
caught was due to Charles Ang's
kleptomania right Charles Eng was uh was
in a hardware store yeah in June of 1985
and he was attempting to steal a bench
vise by sticking it under his jacket
yeah like you do you know which how big
is a bench faces are big right yeah
pretty big
how can you fit it under your cheek he
was just a little skinny dude yeah I
don't know well I guess that's why it
hurt because well cuz the store clerk
like called the cops because it was like
hey there's this little skinny asian man
in here and I'm pretty sure he has
something under the jacket that he's
trying to get out of here now what ended
up happening was you know so they called
the cops so he took off now apparently I
don't know if Leonard Lake was close by
or if Charles Eng had told him he was
going there or if he contacted him
somehow but Leonard lake came to the
hardware store and paid for the vise
okay now when he got there the cops were
already there and he said oh well I just
went inside and pay
for it that was my friend trying to bail
him out right you know it's fine I paid
for it you no need for the cops
yada yada but then the so the cops asked
Leonard for his identification so
Leonard hands over his driver's license
but it was in the name of robbing
Stapley dude that was missing right yeah
and this man was from San Diego and he
was missing and Robin she Stapley was
only 26 years old writing you
so obviously the cops were like I mean
Leonard Lake was much older than that he
was like in her late 30s 38 39 so the
cops were like hmm that's not you I
don't think that's you and also like I
said Robin Shipley um had been reported
missing and you know the photos didn't
even look alike so gonna [ __ ] letter
Jesus but well so okay so then the cops
going since this isn't you
they searched his car and in the trunk
they found a gun with a suppressor yes a
mac-10
which is illegal ruff so well it's not
illegal if you have the license but he
didn't happen he didn't have the light
it was an illegal conversion and a
homemade suppressor yeah yeah exciting
new that that was that that was so
they're like yeah I knew that was
illegal yeah no that's a federal offense
ten years yeah
so they took his fingerprints they
arrested him they took his fingerprints
the fingerprints identified him as
Leonard Lake because obviously it had a
few convictions before while he was at
the police station he asked for a glass
of water yeah they gave him a glass of
water he reached under his lapel popped
something in his mouth drank the water
couple minutes later his eyes rolled
back in his head he started phone with
mouth whatever cyanide pill yeah they
took him to the hospital where he died
before days later but before he did that
he said the one you're looking for is
Charles Nick yeah yeah and so before he
died he admitted who he really was
he gave them Charles ings name and he I
don't think he did he tell them where
where the cabin was or did they are knew
based upon I think vehicle registrations
and where
the venue where he lives yeah because I
think like I said the property I think
was owned by his ex-wife she uh cricket
had taken off by this time but the but
the cabin was owned by his yeah that was
an interesting angle cricket had to have
known that all this capturing women and
killing him the fan she had to have
known that that was going on yeah I'm
not sure like I said it's not real clear
whether she left before that started
happening or after well during the
investigation she went back to that
cabin and stole a bunch of videotapes
that knew that they had made which was a
bunch of evidence of which kata maybe
implicates her in something well I'm
what she said when because she went to
the to the cabin before the cops got
there and then and then she told them oh
I went out there before and they said if
you took any evidence you're in trouble
and she said well all I took with some
videotapes that were just some porn
tapes of me because I didn't want to be
embarrassed yes only her words right
that's what she said yeah who knows what
it was really happy that's what she said
and it so so the [ __ ] swallow cyanide
pills but he confessed everything there
also turned out that the license plate
on his car the plate was registered to
Leonard Lake but the car was registered
to a guy named Paul Costner and he had
been missing since November of 1984 so
since they since they had his plate they
looked up his auto registration and
that's how they found yet the property
and on the property like at this remote
cabin they found Robin stay police truck
and they also found Loni bonds car yeah
two of the people that were missing and
then they looked around the property as
you would and they found the dungeon
behind the cabin when they were looking
around the cabin they also saw foot
poking out of the ground
damn which you know yeah like I said red
flag so they started digging obviously
ended up finding about 40 pounds worth
of burned bone fragments yeah smashed up
yeah now the bone fragments they found
corresponding to about 11 bodies minimum
but probably more
while they were searching the property
they also found a map that Leonard had
drawn and these maps the map led them to
there were these two five-gallon buckets
that have been buried on the property
one of them had envelopes inside it that
had the names and of their victims and
their victims driver's licenses and all
this other stuff now the amount of stuff
the amount of IDs and stuff they were in
this one bucket suggested that maybe
there were as many as 25 victims like I
said a lot of the bodies were smashed up
and burned they were cut up and
everything so they're not entirely sure
how many people were buried there but
according to the IDS that they had it
could have been as many as 25 now the
other bucket contained some journals
that Leonard had written for two entire
years 83 and 84 and it also had
videotapes on which two victims were
being tortured and on one of these tapes
and this will be important later on one
of these tapes
Charles Eng is seen on the videotape and
she is talking to Brenda O'Conner
yeah and he's telling her you know you
can cry like the rest of them but it
won't do any good
you know we're cold hearted or something
like that and he was kind of laughing
about it yeah and um the other the other
tape showed Deborah dubs being tortured
now I was assaulted so severely that she
could have survived but it's been
unclear what was really on the tape that
she couldn't tenser because she's gone
so much so I don't know if they were
beating her to death or what yeah and
like I said I'm not gonna watch that
I'm sure the tape is on the internet
somewhere because the Internet is a dark
and terrible place sometimes no I don't
think so that was VHS and it was
probably pretty well contained by the
cops I think the stuff that's out there
was things that were released oh yeah oh
yeah this stuff I think was destroyed
cuz man I don't wanna say that
I see yeah that's awful but um yeah
because I got to say like I said I'm
fascinated with serial killers but
honestly I don't find I I think I find
them fascinating more not only because
they're evil [ __ ] but I also
because I feel like a lot of empathy
with the victims and what the hell that
must be like I'm like this but I know
especially when you get to that point
where like well it's a serial killer I'm
like oh my god what even goes through
your head I can't imagine so um and that
that [ __ ] keeps me up at night but so in
the meantime so Leonard Lake got off
easy he poisoned himself yeah but
obviously you know he had given them
Charles Aang's name so they started
looking for him now he had taken off for
Canada apparently he got a flight like
before I guess before anyone was really
looking for him he got a flight to
Chicago and then then he got he got into
uh into Canada but that because they do
know he knew there was no death penalty
in Canada yeah that's what happened but
now and they could they wouldn't
extradite from Canada into the United
States if you were facing a death count
well yeah that's that's another yeah
we'll get into that a little bit but he
was actually arrested in Canada um
because he was trying to steal [ __ ]
again yeah well that's what you do dumb
ass legged idiot and it's sad because it
was not sad but it's like you know if he
hadn't just like had to take everything
he saw really have somebody put he had
so many personality flaws that he was
found for failure anyway yeah true yeah
what ended up happening he was he was
shoplifting and when the cops tried to
arrest him he resisted arrest and shot
one of the cops in the hand so you know
so they're like okay well you're under
arrest buddy but at the time they
arrested him in Canada and they weren't
they didn't know that he was that
Charles Lang but he was charged with
shoplifting felonious assault
you know possession of a concealed
firearm yada yada now he was sentenced
to four and a half years in prison while
he was in prison like he did his time
but then like they kept him in prison
because then you know by that time the
US and said hey we want that mother
yeah I didn't know who he was they
didn't who they had for a while yeah
which that's dumb had he not resisted oh
he probably would have been right back
out of jail on that uh shoplifter charge
yeah I mean just shoplifting yeah I mean
yeah and he had an illegal firearm too
but he just had that he would've walked
on the shelves shoplifting and rent then
back out there yeah he's so dumb you
know those aren't the brightest bulbs
what we're talking about you know what I
mean it's not like it's not like
fictional serie it was like Hannibal
Lecter and you super-smart
everything about Sandow and I think the
only reason a lot of them don't get
caught is just cuz of dumb luck
yeah or because people aren't looking
for their victims everybody thought
about how intelligent serial killers are
but you have to understand the criminals
are graded on a curve all right yeah
that's true and like I said if they're
just slightly above average for I think
I'm stupid I think the only reason that
they don't get caught like I said it's
just dumb luck or because they kill
prostitutes or something oh yeah well
you know where people aren't looking too
hard and they're not connected to those
people they're strangers yeah and that
makes it harder as well but so this dick
hole he's in prison in Canada dick oh
yeah gee okay I just uh
he's got ha ha that's it like a cat term
is that so so Charles Lang he's in
prison in Canada u.s. says we want to
extradite him now some sources say that
the Canadian government said no we can't
extradite him because you know they
didn't have the death penalty there and
we said we don't you know we have a
thing where we don't extradite because
we are afraid to get the death penalty
now some other sources say that Charles
Eng was the one that was fighting it the
hardest
like it I like it I don't want to get
sent back right um but eventually so it
was like this huge legal battle where he
where yeah yeah didn't want to actually
I just long campaign of delaying his
trial yeah by all these rusev I hope
these legal moves that he made right
ain't you how to manipulate the way
Canada's legal system yeah yeah because
the whole time he was in prison he was
studying American law like the whole
time like the whole four and a half
years he was in there before they
figured out who he was but um so he kind
of knew his
evidently this it was a big huge legal
battle but eventually um eventually the
Canadian government said no get him out
of here nice and they did send him back
um he was he actually took it all the
way to the Canadian Supreme Court but in
1991 they ruled against him and he was
sent to he was extradited to California
in late 1991 and then there came another
long protracted legal battle that went
on for I think it ended up costing the
state of California like 20 million
dollars or something like yeah they
showed the paperwork and it's like rooms
and rooms of big bad files because did
all this paperwork on this end of school
because what Charles and kept doing was
it seemed like every tiny little detail
he would like I'm suing about that I'm
suing because the food isn't good enough
I'm suing because you made me tired
during a drive here something like it
was all stupid [ __ ] like that yeah
you're trying to bog down the legal
system is slow every yeah which like I
said that he had spent years like
studying him and he knew like all these
little loopholes I guess and [ __ ] like
that so he spent years and years and
years fighting it
when is for Scientology method yeah
exactly they're wearing every one down
he went through like ten attorneys and
then he was gonna sue about that he's
like oh we thought they were incompetent
yeah and then he wanted to represent
himself anyways request he final you he
yeah well that that was actually
successful he did get a change of venue
um to Orange County because he was
originally extradited to Calaveras
County in Calaveras he was indicted on
12 counts of first degree murder and
then but they but they did change into
Orange County because I guess that was
legit because I guess they did some kind
of thing in Calaveras County I was like
father [ __ ] so I guess they thought he
couldn't get a fair trial there whatever
so you know that who was in Brazil what
happened well so he goes for all his
stuff he filed charges against the
judges and all this other [ __ ] like his
eyeglasses weren't strong enough
whatever
oh at his right to practice origami in
general he's still alive but he's still
alive he's alive
well he's on death row cause of death
that senate's come down it was uh yeah
so like I said he went through 1099 uh
now after his extradition he was in
prison in California for six years
before the trial even started because of
all this [ __ ] right and they did let
him represent himself but then that
delayed the trial for yet another year
because that was another whole can of
worms
he's just buying time yeah his defense
he videos up he's getting paler and
paler and fatter and fatter in all this
prison time so it he did get really a
living off a cookies prison cookies
isn't are they like McDonaldland cookies
except with little they're all the
Hamburglar animal crackers this is
Christ okay so they're made out of saw
this is I just get it this kid to this
so Charles Ang's defense it was I mean
you know what possible defense could he
have I'm sure it must be good but uh all
he said was oh I was just an observer
and I was forced into it by Leonard he
was so mean to me yeah and he made me do
all these horrible things above yeah
even though there were all these videos
with his dumb ass right there like
talking to the victim so you can tell
he's into like that yeah yeah and like I
said he had done all this other bad [ __ ]
to it wasn't like he was some [ __ ]
angel cause he still got that he
executed yet at least no all right now
uh he was convicted in 1999 he was he
was convicted of 11 of the 12 which
included six men three women and two
male infants right uh the 12th charge
they didn't have enough evidence but you
know eleven that's enough and they
sensed him to death and uh at the time
that he was convicted his trial
I think the OJ might have been more but
at the time his trial was most expensive
in the state history yeah one is jealous
yeah thanks charlie your tax dollars at
work well not know I talk so it says
California California but well although
you have to admire California because at
some point people like you know we were
we want to spend money on this
[ __ ] and state of California was
like yeah spend all the money you need
just get his ass and Jesse's get his ass
on death row and they did it took a long
time but it took a lot of money but they
eventually did and he is actually still
alive yeah he's in San Quentin man so if
anyone dead by now at ninety nine he was
convicted in ninety nine hurry up
where's the needle well you know how
long it takes and what's really weird
what's really bad about this case is
like all the other little stuff that
came out around it like they were
released drawings that he made in prison
and one of them where he shows them
killing a victim by cooking her over a
fire oh yeah another one evidently what
they would do is they promised these
captured women to the promise that they
would reunite them with their families
and in some of the drawings it shows to
what the reuniting them with their
families was all about they just bring
them a bag of bows burnt Oman so this is
your friends a [ __ ] down video tape er
crying [ __ ] these dudes were in humans
that is a monkey on animals yeah and
then there's another little snippet of
video that came out from that torture
tape at the very end of it looks like
they had recorded over something that
was on there before and but they missed
like a half a second at the very very
end yeah and there's a few frames of a
really creepy photo of a body in rigor
mortis wrapped up I think it might have
been in a sleeping bag and then tied up
and it's in a wheelbarrow if I remember
it's just like stiff with the with a
feet going straight it's just it's
really really creepy and they don't know
who that was one of the ones of them
these dudes were uh oh man cuz like I
said if they killed like 25 victims I'm
not sure they even identified all no
they don't know because you know like I
said egg was only convicted of 11 he was
only um you know he was only charged
with 12 it so those are just the ones
they figured out like you know the other
ones were the ones that are on the
missing first people's cases that were
never solved yes they just never found
them because most of the bodies like I
said they were
crushed up or burned they were burned II
couldn't get DNA out of them yeah it was
the eighties yeah and oh I should say
because you mentioned the the drawings
that was another thing that didn't help
Charles Aang's defense was that while he
was in jail he drew all these little
cartoon drawings of like they're crying
and they used those as evidence he said
he was just messing around but there's
they're so relative to the cases that
they said they you know whoever drew
these obviously was into it and
obviously knew a lot about and they
believe that that stuff happened it made
sense with the evidence or with what
they had yeah so you know not like I
said nothing right not the brightest
bulb and I think I mentioned this
shortly before but I kind of wanted to
go back into this now remember I said
you know Leonard Lake kind of got a lot
of his philosophy from this book what he
called it a fluff yeah not really quiet
colonists icon calling it philosophy
sardonically yeah
with imagine air quotes more like bunny
rabbit ears is the nice artist a fantasy
not so much more like a right but his
favorite book was called the collector
and it was written in 1963 by an English
writer it was his first novel John
Fowles and they made a movie out of it
out of it in 1965 which actually haven't
seen it but I should say that and what
happened in this book is that it's about
this loser guy he was like a clerk and
he's a butterfly collector and he
decides he he falls in love with this
girl from afar like in when he's in
school and you know she she doesn't
really know who he is done given the
time of day whatever I guess she's like
out of his League or what-have-you and
so he decides that just like his
beautiful butterfly club but butterfly
collection he is going to collect this
woman that he loved so much
so he kidnaps her and keeps her you know
in a little bunker or what-have-you in
the in the cellar rather her name is
Miranda and that is that is actually
relevant because in this little secret
room that the cops found in Lake and
Aang's little torture dungeon he had
written
Leonard Lake had written on the wall
like operation Miranda or something like
that with Miranda
in it yeah I think on the Georgia chain
to set em girls or something was the
name yeah and that's what they were
referring to as Miranda who was a
character from this book the collector
and so she there's kind of this whole
thing but eventually the girl ends up
dying but so that's kind of where a lot
of his ideas came from
now the other fascinating thing about
this book was that it apparently um kind
of had associations with a couple other
serial killers too so I know like I'm a
fiction writer and I would hate to think
that one of my books like inspired three
sirak I'm like oh my god what did I
write it yeah like you'd almost kind of
want to like take it back right but you
know you can't control what people are
gonna do with your [ __ ] but you know
what about the way that that book was
written it it really seems to resonate
with the serial killer mind for some
reason or like that type of serial yeah
but this same book was cited as an
inspiration by a guy named Robert Byrd
Ella who killed people in 1988 and also
Christopher Wilder who is known as the
beauty-queen killer yeah and actually he
was a [ __ ] up too like I just saw a
really old cuz this happened in 84 I
think was his thing and I just saw well
do one on him eventually yeah I just saw
a thing about him the other day so I
just thought it was interesting that
weird connection because I was just out
of you know just randomly I was randomly
watching one of those old FBI files
shows or whatever about Christopher
Wilder he's is his stick was basically
he would go into malls and go hey I'm a
photographer oh you're pretty you should
pose for my men he would kidnap them and
break them McCallum so uh like I said I
don't know what it is about this book
now I have to read this book to see not
already dead but what okay read it it'll
it'll turn me into a serial killer
haha it has some kind of weird I don't
know what but uh yeah for some reason
this book really seems to resonate with
that kind of personality and that said
sorry John Fowles I don't know if you're
still alive or not but yeah sorry you
wrote that but uh anyway so we proud a
wrap it up yeah probably yeah it's like
trying
some of the pictures that we can find so
the video stuff out there I did is not
too creepy I'm not like I said I've
already put it up on maximum creepy we
set Mac we can set the creepy level up
to 11 I don't know man I don't wanna I
don't like I said I sat through it this
is bad see this is this is what happens
when you when you write horror and when
you do podcasts about serial killers
you're up at 7:30 in the morning and
you're watching videos of girls being
undressed and tortured by weirdos and
it's really the idea of stuff that's out
there they don't actually show the tour
yeah that's what I mean like but even
the one that I watched like I said the
beginning of it was very crude was just
Leonard like talking about yeah I want
sex slaves bah bah and then there was
one of one of the victims I'm like yeah
now I'm not watching that part and I'm
not you can find it if you watch I said
where's my baby
Oh your baby's sleeping like a stone
that's what the yeah you accept me like
you asked so how to catch those guys
Manju
I'm tested I'm a mana sure yeah well duh
that's why I kind of wish the Punisher
really existed
yeah or Dexter haha yeah I would really
like it if to you know like I'll condone
murder people but honestly people like
this why you don't need that we don't
need that no just take him out no you
know what I mean you know I'm not - not
you guys personally just you know I just
wish someone would and it kind of pisses
me off and this pisses me off about
Christopher Wilder the the model killer
- was that they got off so easy
Leonard link got off so easy he's just
like hey I'm gonna pop some cyanide
tablet he was prepared he had that
cyanide tablet woven into a little patch
that he made yeah his collar and that
kills me because he went ahead yeah that
didn't even occur to me because he me
get arrested for the murders he got
arrested because they found that it was
a new dresser but he knew the jig was up
he knew that that was gonna lead it back
to the to the house
yes registration and everything you
never looked for digging knew that they
were fine so did this time cyanide
tablets like sewed into every shirt that
he owned he probably had little pockets
so it into a lot of them and just put
took that same capsule and put it into
whatever shirt he was wearing of the day
that's how paranoid he was I imagine
once you have that and
how it dude sleeps at night but anyway
well that's go easy yeah that's crazy
yeah why not raises from their point of
view he didn't crazy let his box yeah I
guess I'm gonna be a prisoner was it the
last thing that these kind of guys want
to do is lose power oh yes L so they're
not gonna let the authorities take their
freedom away they'd rather die yeah well
he didn't go down like a kamikaze too
bad there's not a hell okay let's wrap
it up this is good one all right yeah
yeah this was an interest if slightly
icky kind of show so uh you know if you
enjoyed your show like I said hi to all
our new subscribers and all those cool
ass people we met at spooky Empire high
yeah and um oh also I got a remind
everybody we still have t-shirts go to
do shirts WWE as allcom slash 13 o'clock
we still have the five shirts I'm gonna
get to doing new ones too eventually
it's just you know I have a lot of [ __ ]
to do too but you know the five ones
that we have are awesome so you know if
you want to get some and also if you
like the show
subscribe I'll put a little link up go
to our Facebook page 13 o'clock podcasts
go to our Twitter page 13 o'clock 5:00
I'll miss at five o'clock Park that's
the [ __ ] am I talking about I don't know
it's not early that's not an excuse but
yeah you know 13 o'clock podcast we're
all over the place you know and I think
if that'll do it for episode 16 right
that's along alright see you guys next
week bye
you